french police officers patrol a beach at
night near calais
on a mission to prevent migrants and
refugees from trying to cross the
english channel to reach the uk
by boat they've crossed the
mediterranean and survived many dangers
so when they arrive here and see the
last 30 or so kilometers it seems like
nothing
people smugglers charge migrants
thousands of dollars for a place on a
boat
they often use old bunkers like this one
to hide material
we've found boats and life jackets here
in the past what happens is the migrants
wait in the dunes over there the
smugglers retrieve their material
and they all go out to sea there were
nearly ten thousand
attempted crossings last year at least
six people
died police have bolstered security
along the coast
and britain's helping to fund patrols
that now take place around the clock
with some officers on motorbikes
it's a recent phenomenon that's been on
the rise since 2019 because security has
been tightened on
ferries and in the ports it's much
harder to reach the uk by classic means
so migrants are now trying their luck on
inflatable boats
from here you can just about see the
british coastline through the haze it is
less than 40 kilometers away and for the
migrants and refugees that are trying to
cross the english channel
their goal isn't necessarily to reach
the land but to enter uk waters about
halfway because at that point they have
effectively reached britain
many of the migrants are from eritrea
sudan
iraq or afghanistan stuck in squalid
conditions in calais some say that the
police harassed them
we saw officers clear hundreds of people
from a camp
this group of young afghans say that
they'll risk a boat crossing
for a decent life most say they have
friends or family
in england i have one friend who made it
by sea
we have to take a risk by boat scared or
not there's no choice we have to make it
i don't care about the risk because i
left danger in afghanistan
and now it's dangerous to stay here
brexit and the pandemic haven't
dissuaded
some from trying to reach britain or
ended dreams of the sort of safety that
many take for granted
so some people continue to risk their
life for opportunities they believe
lie on the horizon natasha butler al
jazeera
kelly